To many people, our election season sounds like this. You know people are badly watching this. You don't know what's happening. Gentlemen, gentlemen. Well, if I'm going to ask them, I cannot not be the death of a single colleague of the government. The Coffinay and the Squad. No! What the shunna!
对很多人来说，我们的选举季听起来就像这样。你知道人们都在密切关注着。你不知道发生了什么。各位，先生们。好吧，如果我要问他们，我不能不成为政府中某个同僚的死期。Coffinay和小队。不！这算什么！
They are sitting in clusters of Bernie delegates and Hillary delegates. You're kidding! But beneath the rancor, something else is at work. Deep inside the brain, hidden assumptions and frames are shaping the way we think about politics. To understand these forces, we need to step away from the daily barrage of punches and counter punches. We begin 30 miles from the White House on a small farm in Dunkirk, Maryland. Tom Barnes is finishing up for the day. There was one horse I used to do named Refugee. small farm in Dunkirk, Maryland. Tom Barnes is finishing up for the day. He's a
他们成群结队地坐在一起，有伯尼的代表，也有希拉里的代表。你在开玩笑吧！但在这种敌意背后，还有别的东西在起作用。在大脑深处，隐藏的假设和思维框架正在塑造我们对政治的看法。为了理解这些力量，我们需要摆脱日常的唇枪舌剑。我们从距离白宫30英里外马里兰州敦刻尔克的一个小农场开始。汤姆·巴恩斯正在结束一天的劳作。我以前曾经处理过一匹马，名字叫难民。马里兰州敦刻尔克的小农场。汤姆·巴恩斯正在结束一天的劳作。他是一个
farrier, which means he trims and shoots horses hooves all day long. Tom likes to be outside, be his own boss, shape his own future. He believes in hard work, self-reliance, personal responsibility, and these qualities have shaped his political views. Fiscally and internationally conservative, not hard right, but conservative. Tom would never take on too much household debt, and he wants his country to run like his home. I'm real simple when it comes to these kinds of things, and I don't think people should take on more debt than they would be able to repay. And if they can't, I think that there should be consequences
钉蹄师，也就是说他整天都在修剪和钉马蹄铁。汤姆喜欢待在户外，做自己的老板，塑造自己的未来。他相信努力工作、自力更生和个人责任感，这些品质塑造了他的政治观点。在财政和国际事务上是保守的，不算极右，但很保守。汤姆绝不会背负太多的家庭债务，他希望自己的国家能像他的家庭一样运转。在处理这类事情时，我真的很简单，我认为人们不应该承担超过他们偿还能力的债务。如果他们做不到，我认为应该承担相应的后果
for that. And I think that the country is no different, that we should not take on debt, that we can't repay. When he thinks of what ails America, Tom returns to a model of how a family should operate. It's something I've been saying for the last seven what ails America, Tom returns to a model of how a family should operate. It's something I've been saying for the last seven and a half years is that America needs stricter parents, and I truly do feel that way.
为此。我认为国家也没有什么不同，我们不应该承担我们无法偿还的债务。当汤姆思考美国有什么毛病时，他会回归到家庭应该如何运作的模式。这是我过去七年半一直在说的一件事，美国病了，汤姆回归到家庭应该如何运作的模式。这是我过去七年半一直在说的一件事，那就是美国需要更严厉的父母，我确实是这么觉得的。
It goes back to my example earlier of the household budget not getting to a point where they can no longer service their debt. Well, as a country, it's the same type of values that we need to get back to. We need to start being stricter parents. Hundreds of miles away in an urban school district in Indiana, a young high school English teacher has a different perspective shaped by her own values. The school district that I'm in, the specific school that I teach at, is a 73% free and reduced lunch school.
这可以追溯到我刚才举的例子，即家庭预算没有达到无法再偿还债务的地步。嗯，作为一个国家，我们需要回归的也是这种价值观。我们需要开始做更严厉的父母。几百英里外，在印第安纳州的一个城市学区，一位年轻的高中英语教师有着由她自己的价值观塑造的不同视角。我所在的学区，我教书的具体学校，是一所73%的学生享受免费和减价午餐的学校。
And also, we are a minority majority school where we are 34% white students. Kate Borkat doesn't just think government supported lunch programs are useful. She knows it. I think I've just seen what can be done with government money kind of putting a face to you know you hear all these statistics about oh it's a free and reduced lunch school but I don't think about it like that I know these kids and I've known them for years and I've seen the good that they go on to do in the world and it's worth it it's worth the investment. Tom and Kate have
而且，我们也是一所少数族裔占多数的学校，其中34%是白人学生。凯特·博卡特不仅仅认为政府支持的午餐计划很有用。她深知这一点。我想我只是看到了政府资金能做些什么，给它赋予一张脸，你知道你听到了所有这些关于“哦，这是一所享受免费和减价午餐的学校”的统计数据，但我不是这么想的，我认识这些孩子，我已经认识他们多年了，我看到了他们继续在世界上做出的好事，这是值得的，这是值得投资的。汤姆和凯特
good reasons to believe what they do. They're reasonable people with deeply held convictions. But put millions of TARMS and millions of KATES together, and what you see isn't reasonable disagreement. Increasingly, Democrats and Republicans can't comprehend the others point of view. It's not just the current campaign. Beyond the noise of the contest between Republican presidential candidate Donald Trump and Democrat Hillary Clinton,
有充分的理由相信他们的所作所为。他们是讲道理的人，有着坚定的信念。但是，把数百万像汤姆这样的人和数百万像凯特这样的人放在一起，你看到的并不是合理的意见分歧。民主党人和共和党人越来越无法理解对方的观点。这不仅仅是当前的竞选。在共和党总统候选人唐纳德·特朗普和民主党人希拉里·克林顿之间争夺战的喧嚣背后，
lies a gulf of distrust and misunderstanding. How do we get to a divide that feels so unbridgeable? Here's one theory. What if a driving force behind our political preferences is something we're not even aware of? They're like unconscious ideologies in a way that is their beliefs or convictions that we hold that are non-consciously hell but nonetheless influence the way we interpret the world. Today's show the hidden moral frameworks that shape our politics. Stay with us. One night, decades ago, George Lekov began a quest. He was listening to speeches from a gathering of conservative politicians. They were blasting the idea that people
隐藏着不信任和误解的鸿沟。我们是如何陷入这种感觉如此不可逾越的分裂的呢？这是一个理论。如果推动我们政治偏好的背后力量是我们甚至没有意识到的东西呢？它们在某种程度上就像无意识的意识形态，也就是说，是我们潜意识中持有的信仰或信念，但它们仍然会影响我们解释世界的方式。今天的节目将探讨塑造我们政治的隐藏道德框架。请继续收听。几十年前的一个晚上，乔治·莱科夫开始了一项探索。他正在听保守派政治家集会上的演讲。他们猛烈抨击这样一种观点：
who worked hard to earn more money should pay more in taxes. And everybody there clapped and waved their arms, waved their signs, etc. The conservatives were making a moral argument. To George, it seemed self-evidently wrong. But to the cheering conservatives, it seemed self-evidently wrong. But to the cheering conservatives, it seems self-evidently right. George has to himself how two people could look at the same issue and draw such radically different conclusions. In 1994, it happened again. George had a sense that the people on the other side of the aisle were from another planet.
那些努力工作赚取更多钱的人应该缴纳更多税款。在场的每个人都鼓掌、挥舞手臂、挥舞标语等等。保守派在进行道德辩论。对乔治来说，这似乎是不言而喻的错误。但对欢呼的保守派来说，这似乎是不言而喻的错误。但对欢呼的保守派来说，这似乎是不言而喻的正确。乔治纳闷，为什么两个人会对同一个问题得出如此截然不同的结论。1994年，这种情况再次发生。乔治有一种感觉，认为大厅另一边的人来自另一个星球。
This time it was Republican- Newt Gingrich talking. Think of America as a giant family of 260 million people of extraordinarily diverse backgrounds, riding in a huge car down the highway. Newt Gingrich was hawking his contract with America. He warned that the tires of the family car were blowing out. America is in trouble, and our trouble extends beyond the White House.
这一次是共和党人纽特·金里奇在发言。把美国想象成一个拥有2.6亿人口的巨大代孕家庭，这些人口具有极其多样化的背景，坐在一辆开在高速公路上的大车里。纽特·金里奇在兜售他的《与美国契约》。他警告说，家庭汽车的轮胎快要爆了。美国陷入了麻烦，我们的麻烦不仅限于白宫。
Newt Gingrich offered an ambitious package of policies that covered a range of traditional conservative issues. As he listened, George started thinking about the whole Republican platform. He decided it was an incoherent mess. What does the flat tax have to do with environmental regulations? What does that have to do with environmental regulations? What does that have to do with owning guns?
纽特·金里奇提出了一揽子雄心勃勃的政策，涵盖了一系列传统的保守派议题。听着听着，乔治开始思考整个共和党纲领。他认为这是一团毫无逻辑的乱麻。单一税与环境法规有什么关系？这与环境法规有什么关系？这与拥有枪支有什么关系？
And what does the death penalty have to do with being pro-life? All of those things seem strange to me. Republicans looking at the democratic platform might say the very same thing. George looked at his own bewilderment with curiosity. This feeling of utter incomprehension is an experience widely shared by people on both sides of the aisle. How could it be, he asked himself, that millions of Americans firmly believe that the views of millions of other Americans are incoherent? As George tried to figure out what was going on, something popped in his head. It seemed tangential, but he thought it might be a clue.
死刑与反堕胎有什么关系？所有这些事情对我都显得很奇怪。看着民主党纲领的共和党人可能会说同样的话。乔治带着好奇心审视着自己的困惑。这种彻底无法理解的感觉是两党民众广泛共有的一种体验。他问自己，为什么数百万美国人坚信数百万其他美国人的观点是毫无逻辑的呢？正当乔治试图弄清楚发生了什么时，他的脑海中突然冒出一个想法。这似乎离题了，但他认为这可能是一个线索。
We heard it in something Newt Gingrich just said. Think of America as a giant family of 260 million people. That's a metaphor. George Lekoff, as it happens, is a cognitive linguist and an expert on metaphors. One of the things he's discovered is that metaphors are far more powerful than most people think. They aren't just figures of speech, but ways to organize how we see the world. George started to wonder about this metaphor of the country as a family. Did it have something to do with the mutual incomprehension that Democrats and Republicans feel toward one another?
我们在纽特·金里奇刚刚说过的话中听到了这一点。把美国想象成一个2.6亿人的庞大家庭。这是一个隐喻。碰巧的是，乔治·莱科夫是一位认知语言学家，也是隐喻专家。他发现的一件事是，隐喻比大多数人想象的要强大得多。它们不仅仅是修辞手法，更是组织我们如何看待世界的方式。乔治开始对把国家比作家庭的这个隐喻产生好奇。这是否与民主党人和共和党人之间感到的相互不理解有关？
The moment this notion occurred to him, he started seeing examples everywhere. We have a metaphor that the nation is a family. We have founding fathers. We send our sons and daughters to war. We have homeland security. We don't want missiles in our backyard and so on and so on. And the idea that occurred to me, that if that's the case,
当这个概念浮现在他脑海的那一刻，他开始到处看到例子。我们有一个国家是一个家庭的隐喻。我们有国父。我们把儿子和女儿送上战场。我们有国土安全。我们不希望导弹落在我们的后院，诸如此类。而我想到的一个想法是，如果情况确实如此，
if you have two different views of the nation, you may have two different views of the family. So I worked backwards. I took the two different views of the nation, worked backwards through the metaphor, and out popped two different views of the family. In other words, if both Republicans and Democrats think of the nation as a kind of family, but
如果你对国家有两种不同的看法，你可能对家庭也有两种不同的看法。所以我逆向推导。我采用了对国家的两种不同的看法，通过隐喻逆向推导，然后蹦出了对家庭的两种不同的看法。换句话说，如果共和党人和民主党人都认为国家是一种家庭，但
have very different assumptions on how a family ought to work, could those assumptions be behind our seemingly irreconcilable differences? On its surface, the idea that the way we think about family can shape the way we think about politics is crazy. This is where George Lekop's earlier work on metaphors comes in. Metaphors are powerful precisely because they operate on a largely unconscious level. They are the lens through which we see the world, but most of the time we don't realize they're even there. Think again about our
对家庭应该如何运作有着截然不同的假设，这些假设是否是我们看似不可调和的分歧背后的原因？表面上看，我们对家庭的看法会塑造我们对政治的看法，这个想法简直是疯了。这就是乔治·莱科夫先前关于隐喻的研究发挥作用的地方。隐喻之所以强大，正是因为它们在很大程度上是在无意识的层面上运作的。它们是我们看待世界的镜头，但大多数时候我们甚至没有意识到它们的存在。再次想想我们的
failure, Tom Barnes, and Woody Wands for the Country. America needs stricter parents. They're like unconscious ideologies in a way. That is their beliefs or convictions that we hold that are non-consciously hell, but nonetheless influence the way we interpret the world. This is Marty Gonzalez. She's a psychologist who's done her own research on George Leakoff's theories
失败，汤姆·巴恩斯，以及为了国家的伍迪·万兹。美国需要更严格的父母。它们在某种程度上就像无意识的意识形态。也就是说，是我们潜意识中持有的信仰或信念，但它们仍然会影响我们解释世界的方式。这是玛蒂·冈萨雷斯。她是一位心理学家，她对乔治·莱科夫关于我们对家庭的看法如何塑造我们的政治观点的理论进行了自己的研究
about how the way we think about families can shape our political views. George and Marty think that most Americans embrace one of two different models of family. Now, these are generalizations and they have lots of exceptions, but let's start with the basic models. One is what they call the strict father model. The strict father family, the parents in that family, tend to view the world as a really complex,
乔治和玛蒂认为，大多数美国人都拥抱两种不同的家庭模式中的一种。现在，这些都是概括，它们有很多例外，但让我们从基本的模式开始。其中一个是他们所说的严格父亲模型。严父家庭，那个家庭中的父母，往往把世界视为一个非常复杂、
and dangerous, and unfriendly place. It's tough love. In the strict father family, the father knows best. The father knows right from wrong, and the job of the father is not just the support and protect the family, but also with respect to children, is to teach them right from wrong
危险且不友好的地方。这是严厉的爱。在严父家庭中，父亲最懂。父亲懂得对错，父亲的职责不仅是支持和保护家庭，而且对于孩子来说，是教导他们对错
so that they have their right moral views. Competition, of course, is a good thing from the point of view of strict father families. Because success at competition rewards people for the strength and the tenacity, the self-discipline, and the self-reliance that enable the person to succeed. Now I think the term strict father feels a little outdated. I might call it a strict parent family, since one or both parents might have this parenting style.
以便他们有正确的道德观点。从严父家庭的角度来看，竞争当然是一件好事。因为竞争中的成功奖励了人们的力量和坚韧、自律和自力更生，这些使人能够成功。现在我认为“严父”这个词感觉有点过时了。我可能会称之为严格父母家庭，因为父母双方或其中一方可能有这种育儿风格。
Strict parents who love their children believe it would be wrong to send them out into a dangerous world unprepared for what it has in store for them. Strict parents believe they need to make that children tough and self-reliant. So the central metaphor of the strict father family is, what is good is what is strong. Again, a farrier, Tom Barnes. I'm a firm believer that when America is strong,
深爱孩子的严格父母认为，把他们送进一个危险的世界，却对它所蕴含的一切毫无准备，那是错误的。严格父母认为他们需要让孩子变得坚强和自力更生。因此，严父家庭的核心隐喻是：强者为善。再次，钉蹄师，汤姆·巴恩斯。我坚信，当美国强大时，
the world is a safe place. And I don't think in the last seven and a half years we've we've really stood by that. I think we've tried to be more of one of the gang than someone that our allies can count on and that our enemies respect and I don't want to see that going any further than it already has. that going further than it already has. There is another model of how to be a good parent. George and Marty call this style, notchurant.
世界就是一个安全的地方。我不认为在过去的七年半里，我们真正坚持了这一点。我认为我们试图成为帮派中的一员，而不是我们的盟友可以依靠、我们的敌人会尊重的人，我不希望这种情况比现在更进一步。这种情况不会再进一步发展了。还有另一种如何成为好父母的模式。乔治和玛蒂称这种风格为：温和。
I think of these parents as empathetic parents. They believe that notchur, empathy, and trust, these are the tools that help children grow into their fullest cells. The goal of this kind of parent is to rear children who are happy and self-fulfilled. Their job is to empathize with their child to know what their child needs, to have an open two-way discussions with their child. They have to develop a set of kind of values along the way or beliefs along the way, among them them, as a society benefit, when people are willing to care for, support, and nurture other people.
我认为这些父母是有同理心的父母。他们相信抚育、同理心和信任，这些是帮助孩子成长为最完整的自我的工具。这种父母的目标是抚养快乐和自我实现的儿童。他们的工作是与孩子共情，了解孩子需要什么，与孩子进行开放的双向讨论。他们必须在成长过程中发展出一套价值观或信念，其中包括：当人们愿意关怀、支持和培育他人时，社会就会受益。
Our teacher, Kate Borkat, exemplifies this thinking when it comes to the children in her care. I think it's the right thing to take care of people. I just do. I don't, maybe that's the Catholic upbringing in me, but it's right to take care of people that need it. We'll get to the evidence for George and Marty's theory about how our views of the family can shape our political outlook, but I have to say this idea has immense intuitive appeal. The earliest experience all of us have with authority and leadership is within the family. You're first governed in your family. And so we arrive at metaphors in which we are unconscious metaphors, in which governing institutions are families. This was a pivotal moment in Georgia's search for understanding.
我们的老师凯特·博卡特在对待她所照顾的孩子时，就体现了这种思维方式。我认为照顾人是正确的事情。我只是这么认为。我不，也许那是我的天主教背景，但照顾需要帮助的人是正确的。我们来看看乔治和玛蒂关于我们对家庭的看法如何塑造我们的政治观点的理论证据，但我必须说这个想法具有巨大的直观吸引力。我们所有人对权威和领导力的最早体验都是在家庭内部。你首先是在你的家庭中被管理的。因此，我们得出了隐喻，其中我们是无意识的隐喻，其中管理机构就是家庭。这是乔治寻找理解过程中的一个关键时刻。
If people see families as governing bodies and governing bodies playing the role of parents, isn't it possible they use their own family and upbringing families as governing bodies and governing bodies playing the role of parents. Isn't it possible they use their own family and upbringing as an unconscious model of how government ought to work? Marty decided to test Georgia's hypothesis that unconscious parenting models show up all the time in our nation's politics. She and her team analyzed all the presidential political ads that have played on daytime and prime time TV,
如果人们将家庭视为治理机构，而治理机构扮演父母的角色，难道他们不可能将自己的家庭和抚养方式作为政府应该如何运作的无意识模型吗？玛蒂决定检验乔治的假设，即无意识的育儿模式在我国政治中一直表现出来。她和她的团队分析了自1980年以来在日间和黄金时段电视上播放的所有总统政治广告。
going all the way back to 1980. She had research assistants listen to the ads and code them, according to whether they had underlying metaphors that spoke to the idea of the strict parent and the empathetic parent. The bottom line is, Professor George Lackoff was right. Now, to be clear, lots of the ads were simply one candidate attacking the other. Many of them talked about issues in the news, but a significant number made appeals to voters unconscious moral frameworks drawing on the themes of the strict and empathetic parent. Jimmy Carter still doesn't know that it takes strong leadership to keep the peace.
她让研究助理聆听广告并进行编码，根据它们是否具有传达严格父母和同理心父母思想的潜在隐喻。底线是，乔治·莱科夫教授是对的。现在，明确地说，很多广告仅仅是一个候选人攻击另一个候选人。他们中的许多人谈论了新闻中的问题，但有相当一部分诉诸选民无意识的道德框架，汲取了严格和富有同理心的父母的主题。吉米·卡特仍然不知道需要强有力的领导来保持和平。
I believe we need to encourage personal responsibility so people are accountable for their actions. Republicans were much more likely to rely on strict father ideas to make their points to persuade voters. Democrats were much more likely to use nurtured parent ideas. I don't think Reagan showed enough compassion for the people of California. Told the insurance company don't do this, don't cut this child's coverage. Al Gore got the Malone family, the help they needed. We believe in a solid, just compassionate, hopeful future. Now these are broad archetypes, of course.
我相信我们需要鼓励个人责任，以便人们对自己的行为负责。共和党人更有可能依赖严格的父亲想法来阐述他们的观点，以说服选民。民主党人更有可能使用受过良好教育的父母的想法。我认为里根对加利福尼亚人民表现出的同情心不够。告诉保险公司不要这样做，不要削减这个孩子的保险。戈尔得到了马龙一家的帮助，得到了他们需要的帮助。我们相信一个坚实、公正、富有同情心、充满希望的未来。当然，这些都是广泛的原型。
Parents can be both strict and empathetic. Parents can disagree with one another about the importance of rules and structure. But as we grow up, these models, both based on love, both based on the certainty that this is the best way to raise kids, shape the way many of us see the world. From the moment Georgian Marty described how Republicans and Democrats draw on different parenting models, I started to see examples of this everywhere. Here's an ad from the Trump campaign featuring the voice of his son Donald Trump Jr. deals with China and Mexico. It's that toughness that I want keeping me and my family and your family safe. My father will make an incredible president. And here's an ad from Hillary Clinton. When I think about why I'm doing this,
父母既可以严格又可以富有同理心。父母可能对规则和结构的重要性持不同意见。但是随着我们长大，这些模式都建立在爱之上，都建立在确信这是抚养孩子的最好方式的基础上，塑造了我们许多人看待世界的方式。从乔治和玛蒂描述共和党人和民主党人如何借鉴不同的育儿模式的那一刻起，我开始到处看到这种例子的身影。这是特朗普竞选团队的一则广告，使用了他的儿子小唐纳德·特朗普的声音：与中国和墨西哥的协议。正是这种坚韧让我、我的家人和你的家人保持安全。我的父亲将成为一位了不起的总统。这是希拉里·克林顿的一则广告。当我想起我为什么要这样做时，
I think about my mother Dorothy. She was abandoned by her parents at the age of eight, sent from Chicago to LA to live with grandparents who didn't want her. But people showed her kindness, gave her a chance. Like the teacher who saw my mother had no money for food and started bringing her extra from home whispering,
我想起了我的母亲多萝西。她八岁时被父母抛弃，从芝加哥送到洛杉矶，和不想要她的祖父母住在一起。但人们对她表现出善良，给了她一个机会。就像那个老师看到我母亲没有钱买食物，开始从家里给她带额外的食物，低声说道：
you know Dorothy, I just brought too much food today. She went to work in somebody else's home at age 14 and it opened her eyes. For the first time, she saw parents who loved and cared for their children. And that's the kind of loving family she provided for us. When she needed a champion, someone was there. I think about all the Dorothy's, all over America,
你知道多萝西，我今天带的食物太多了。她14岁就在别人家工作，这让她大开眼界。她第一次看到了爱和关怀自己孩子的父母。这就是她为我们提供的充满爱的家庭。当她需要捍卫者时，有人在那里。我想象全美国所有的多萝西，
who fight for their families, who never give up. That's why I'm doing this. That's why I've always done this. For all the dorthies. Are you feeling a lump in your throat? If so, it might be because you have an empathetic model of parenting at the back of your head. On the other hand, if the ad sounded like sentimental coddling and you are drawn more to the trump ad, it might be because your model of the family is built around the idea of a strict parent. I asked Marty to play a little game with me and
为了他们的家庭而战，永不放弃。这就是我为什么要这样做的原因。这就是我一直以来都在做的原因。为了所有的多萝西。你有没有感到喉咙哽咽？如果是这样，那可能是因为你的脑海深处有一个富有同理心的育儿模式。另一方面，如果这则广告听起来像是多愁善感的溺爱，而你更被特朗普的广告所吸引，那可能是因为你的家庭模式建立在严格父母的理念之上。我请玛蒂和我玩一个小游戏，
imagine how people who disagree with Trump and Clinton might see an ad put out by the other side. How would a strict parent view that Clinton add about her mother? Here's all this mushy stuff about feelings and taking care of people and when you take care of people, of course, you know you're undermining their self-reliance and you're not doing them any good. And in this dangerous world, we don't need a person who can empathize with our enemies or find common ground with our enemies.
想象一下那些不同意特朗普和克林顿观点的人会如何看待另一方发布的广告。一个严格的父母会如何看待克林顿关于她母亲的广告？这里有所有关于感情和照顾人的糊涂事，当你照顾人时，当然，你知道你正在削弱他们的自力更生，你对他们没有任何好处。在这个危险的世界里，我们不需要一个能够与我们的敌人共情或与我们的敌人找到共同点的人。
We need someone strong enough to stand up and protect us from them. And here's a hypothetical voter with the empathetic parent model on the Trump ad. Well, if Donald Trump thinks that to govern, the only thing he needs is toughness and strength were in for a bumpy ride. Once people start governing, being tough isn't going to be enough. You need to be open to new ideas. You need to be open to the idea of cooperating
我们需要一个足够强大的人站出来保护我们免受他们的伤害。这里有一个具有同理心父母模式的假想选民，针对特朗普的广告。好吧，如果唐纳德·特朗普认为治理国家唯一需要的就是坚韧和力量，那我们将经历一段坎坷的旅程。一旦人们开始治理国家，仅仅坚韧是不够的。你需要对新想法持开放态度。你需要对合作的想法持开放态度
with people across the aisle. It's interesting that this is the cartoon version that each side has of the other, that each side and separate from Clinton and Trump, sort of the division, the partisan division that we have in the country is very much this division where many progressives think of conservatives as being heartless cruel people. And then- It's not Neanderthals, you know? Yeah, and many conservatives think of progress as being heartless cruel people. And not meanderthals. Yeah, and many conservatives think of progressives as just being brained at. Right, right.
与跨党派的人合作。有趣的是，这就是双方对彼此的漫画版本，每一方都与克林顿和特朗普分开，某种程度上，我们国家的这种分裂，这种党派分裂非常类似于这种分裂，许多进步派认为保守派是冷酷残酷的人。然后——不是尼安德特人，你知道吗？是的，许多保守派认为进步派是冷酷残酷的人。不是尼安德特人。是的，许多保守派认为进步派只是头脑简单。对，对。
And the sad thing is these kinds of ads get people riled up and more willing to embrace more strongly the moral foundations of their political ideology such that when elections are over and the process of governing begins, you have citizens on the one hand who still can't pull together, you know, across the ideological divide, and you certainly have mandates from these citizens to send their representatives to Washington, not to negotiate, not to give in to the silly strict father or the silly nurturant parent orientations of our elected leaders. When people draw on moral frameworks that we don't share, what they say can seem incomprehensible.
可悲的是，这类广告激起了人们的情绪，让他们更愿意强烈拥抱其政治意识形态的道德基础，以至于当选举结束、治理过程开始时，一方面公民仍然无法团结起来（跨越意识形态的分裂），而且你肯定会从这些公民那里得到授权，派遣他们的代表去华盛顿，不是去谈判，不是向我们民选领导人愚蠢的严父或愚蠢的关怀父母导向妥协。当人们利用我们不共享的道德框架时，他们所说的话可能显得不可理解。
And what happens when you hear things that don't make sense, there are various things you can do about it. One, you can just not hear it. It doesn't make any sense. You do about it. One, you can just not hear it. It doesn't make any sense. You can ignore it. You can ridicule it, saying, hey, this doesn't make any sense. There's stupid people, there dumb, there mean, there cruel, whatever. Or you can, if it's threatening, you can attack them. And very often there's an attack. So all of those things are happening in our politics right now. So, all of those things are happening in our politics right now. And they're normal, you'd expect them to happen, given the way that people's brains work
当你听到没有意义的事情时会发生什么，你可以做各种各样的事情。第一，你可以不听。这没有任何意义。你可以对此无动于衷。你可以忽略它。你可以嘲笑它，说，嘿，这没有任何意义。这些人很蠢，他们很笨，他们很卑鄙，他们很残酷，诸如此类。或者你可以，如果它具有威胁性，你可以攻击他们。通常会有攻击。所以所有这些事情现在都在我们的政治中发生。所以，所有这些事情现在都在我们的政治中发生。它们很正常，鉴于人们大脑工作的方式，你预计它们会发生
and given the fact that we have alternative worldviews. But the idea that we have alternative worldviews is not in our public discourse. To be sure, there are plenty of exceptions to this model of how we come to our political views. Race, religion, immigration, class, gender, all play a role in shaping our politics. George Lekoff and Marty Gonzalez' ideas don't displace everything else we know about how politics works, but it's a point of view you might not have considered. Even within this theory, this room for nuance and complexity, a person may have both strict
鉴于我们拥有替代世界观这一事实。但是我们拥有替代世界观的想法并不在我们的公共话语中。可以肯定的是，对于我们如何形成政治观点的这一模型有很多例外。种族、宗教、移民、阶级、性别都在塑造我们的政治中发挥着作用。乔治·莱科夫和玛蒂·冈萨雷斯的观点并没有取代我们对政治运作方式的其他所有了解，但这是一个你可能没有考虑过的观点。即使在这个理论内部，也有细微差别和复杂性的空间，一个人可能同时拥有严格的
and empathetic parenting models to guide them. They can follow one model at home and another at work. You can certainly find Republican ads that feature empathy and Democratic ads that project strength. Unconscious moral frameworks don't explain everything, but they do explain some things that otherwise seem inexplicable. How you understand your world and what you're supposed to be doing and who you respect and who you don't respect and what you want to do in your life and so on, and how you understand everything around you. So here's one way to think about this political season. The nation is in the middle of a parenting dispute. Each side feels the other is on the wrong path, and so much is at stake.
和富有同理心的育儿模式来指导他们。他们可以在家里遵循一种模式，在工作时遵循另一种模式。你当然可以找到突出同理心的共和党广告和展现力量的民主党广告。无意识的道德框架并不能解释一切，但它们确实解释了一些原本似乎无法解释的事情。你如何理解你的世界，你被认为应该做什么，你尊重谁，你不尊重谁，你想在你的生活中做什么，诸如此类，以及你如何理解你周围的一切。所以这是思考这个政治季的一种方式。国家正处于育儿纠纷之中。每一方都觉得对方走错了路，而且关系重大。
Parents who adhere to one or another conception of the ideal family want what's good for their children, and they parent in ways that they believe, firmly believe, with love in their hearts that will most benefit their children in this complex world. Like two parents who love their child but can't get along with each other, our political parties each believe they have the right answer to what the country needs. All of us feel bewilder that policies that seem so self-evidently correct to us are rejected by the other side. Understandably, we explain these differences by pointing fingers and questioning each other's motives. The truth is much harder. What fuels our inflexible certainty isn't stupidity or callousness.
坚持某种理想家庭概念的父母希望他们的孩子好，他们以他们认为的、坚信的、带着心中的爱去育儿的方式，在这个复杂的世界里最有利于他们的孩子。就像两个爱着孩子却无法相处融洽的父母一样，我们的政党各自坚信他们对国家的需求有着正确的答案。我们所有人都感到困惑，为什么在我们看来不言而喻的正确的政策会被另一方拒绝。可以理解的是，我们通过指责和质疑彼此的动机来解释这些差异。事实要残酷得多。助长我们这种死板确定性的不是愚钝或冷酷。
It's love. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Pennman and Chris Vendereff. It was edited by Tara Boyle. We had original music from Ramteen Arabloewing. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter and listen to my stories each week on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, please give us a review. It helps others find the show. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是爱。本期的《隐藏大脑》由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和克里斯·温德雷夫制作。塔拉·博伊尔进行了剪辑。我们有来自拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布洛温的原创音乐。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多《隐藏大脑》的内容，并每周在你的当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。